okay so in this presentation we're gonna
go over some of the basic features of
flowering plants and that's what
angiosperms are angiosperms are plants
that produce flowers will they also
produce a few other things let's go
ahead and get started so I brought up in
my previous video on gymnosperms I
brought up the fact that gymnosperms our
seed producing and vascular so our
angiosperms that's why it says type 2
type 1 was my other video and
gymnosperms so angiosperms are what we
call flowering plants and they are seed
producing and they are vascular so as I
just mentioned they're flowering plants
and so here's a diagram of a flower and
what I want you to know is the flower is
the reproductive organ so when flowers
are blooming and when you can see a
flower on a plant it's trying to
reproduce and so the whole purpose of a
flower is to usually attract some kind
of pollinator in the top picture we have
a moth in the bottom picture we have a
hummingbird but usually the flowers are
brightly colored they have a play a
pleasing aroma often they have a sweet
nectar Eve liquidy treat to reward the
pollinator for coming over to
investigate
and so the purpose of a flower is to
attract the pollinator the pollinator
will spread pollen and eventually if
fertilization occurs a fruit will form
so at the base of a flower and we'll
talk more about this later on at the
base of a flower eventually a fruit
might develop such as an apple and in
that apple there will be seeds so seeds
are inside of the fruit and eventually
those seeds are going to be dispersed
but when we will talk about seed
dispersal more in just a moment but
eventually the seeds are going to be
dispersed but inside of the seeds you've
seen this picture before if you watched
some of the other videos are or is an
embryo
and in this picture the green colored
embryos trapped inside the seed but it's
gonna feed off of the food supply until
the seed cracks open and that little
green baby plant will be able to do
photosynthesis but not until the seed
cracks open
so I brought up seed dispersal just a
moment ago and so seeds are often
brightly colored they often have a nice
sweet taste to them and again they often
have a pleasing aroma their whole
purpose is to be eaten eaten fruits are
designed to be eaten because of what's
inside the seed and so when an animal
eats a seed in the animation looks like
the horse is doing a handstand and
eating the Apple I have a picture here
of the horses digestive system for a
reason the apple and the seeds will pass
through the digestive system in this
case of the horse and the horse gallops
away and eventually the horse will stop
galloping and eventually go to the
bathroom and in that pile of manure or
dung in that pile of poop are seeds the
seeds that can begin to grow some
distance away from the original parent
plant here we have a couple pictures of
poop bird poop on the Left Fox
poop on the right and especially in the
Fox Fox droppings you can see the
clusters of seeds there so the Fox ate
some fruit and ran away and then
eventually went to the bathroom and
dropped the seeds in in in its poop
so I want to mention a couple kinds of
angiosperms there's two big big
subcategories of angiosperms two big
groups and what we call that we call
them from the picture monocots and
dicots
and the cat in monocots the cat in dicot
refers to what's called a cattle eaten a
cattle eaten is simply the name of that
little embryonic leaf you saw a picture
a few moments ago of that embryo trapped
inside of the seed well you notice that
there were if you go back to the video
there was one leaf attached to that to
that embryo that would be an example of
a monocot and from the picture you can
see the monocot on the left when it
begins to germinate and grow you can see
early on it's gonna only have one seed
early on excuse me it's early on it's
only gonna have one leaf one leaf early
on in its life it'll eventually of
course grow many others but early on
it's going to only have one leaf dicots
you can see in the picture early in
their life as an embryo when they start
to to germinate and grow dicots only
have two leaves at the start again a cat
is in reference to the cattle eden the
little baby embryonic leaf that that
they possess early on in their in their
development so these are the two broad
categories monocot and dicot there's a
really easy way to identify if a
angiosperm is a monocot or a dicot and
in this picture it shows the real two
easy ways if you look at if you pluck
off a leaf of let's say a tree look at
the veins on the leaf if it's a monocot
the veins are all going to run parallel
in one direction if the tree is a dicot
like in the bottom picture the veins of
the leaf are gonna branch out in a
net-like pattern another way to figure
out if a plant is a monocot or a dicot
is to look at the flower parts if it's a
monocot the flower parts going to be in
multiples of three so maybe it'll have
three petals or six petals in the bottom
picture if you to count the flower parts
they will usually be in multiples of
four or five so if it has maybe ten
flower parts ten
well then you know you have yourself a
dicot let's practice that right now
so here's a picture of an apple trees
leaf and an apple trees flower so an
apple tree you can see a couple things
that lets you know if it's a monocot or
a dicot in the leaf you can see that the
veins are net like they branch in
various directions they do not run
parallel and if you count up the flower
the flower petals right there you can
see there's five flower petals this I
hope you can see is a die cut here's
another example of a flower right here
and if you count up the flower petals
you can see the hey there's six flower
petals that's a multiple of three that
means this has to be a monocot in this
one you can see a few things in the
picture you can see that it's a monocot
because of the three flower petals and
in the background you can see the veins
I'll run one direction they veins all
run parallel how about this one I'm
gonna show the answer in three two one
well this one's a dicot cuz if you count
the flower petals you see there are five
multiples of five is a dicot how about
this one I didn't give you a flower I
only gave you its leaf I hope you see
that the veins all run parallel that's
characteristic of a monocot it see how
easy this is here's another one and
again I hope you can see for the same
reason as the previous picture the veins
all run up and down parallel it's a
monocot
a couple more and we'll be done here is
a leaf right here again no flowers
needed hope you chose dicot because all
the the veins branch outward in various
directions okay so moving on angiosperms
go through a few patterns that we've
noticed when it comes to how long they
live their lifespan we've noticed three
basic patterns when it comes to the
lifespan of angiosperms
there are angiosperms that are called
annuals because they only live one year
that's it they do their entire existence
in one year in our timeline up here
early on in the year so early on like in
the month of March the seed is gonna
germinate and that simply means that it
starts to grow and then during the
summer months the plant will get bigger
and bigger and bigger now it's not going
to grow into a gigantic tree not that
doesn't happen all in one year so these
are usually really small flowering
plants and in the autumn in the autumn
in the fall usually it's going to
produce a flower and if fertilization
and pollination are successful the
flower will grow a fruit which will have
seeds trapped inside and then before the
winter months come the plant dies that's
okay that a died because it made seeds
and therefore it will continue on with
the next generation but all that happens
in one year so they're very small plants
annuals
the other pattern that we happen is a
two-year pattern these are called
biennials do not mix up biennial with
biannual if an event is biannual that
means it happens twice in one year but
in this case biennials means that they
live for two years so early on in year
number one the seed germinates which
means it just starts to grow and then
over the next few months the plant gets
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and then at the end of year number one
it's gonna go into a dormant hibernative
state and that'll carry over into year
number two in the year number two that
dormant dormant hibernative state will
continue but then when year number two
when springtime rolls around and it gets
warmer then the plant will continue to
grow a little bit and near the end of
year two if fertilization and
pollination are successful it will
produce fruits with seeds inside and
then near the end of year number two the
plant will die that's okay because it
made seeds the seeds will be dispersed
and will carry on the existence of this
particular species
okay and the third and final lifespan
that we notice are called perennials and
these things live for more than two
years they might they might live for
decades even centuries and so what we
notice is in the beginning of year
number one a seed is gonna germinate the
seed is gonna grow and over the course
of the next few months the plant will
grow and get bigger and just like we've
seen before during the winter during the
winter that plant will go into a dormant
hibernate of state that'll carry on over
into year number two
well when the weather warms up in the
springtime the plant will continue to
grow during all those summer those warm
spring summer and autumn months near the
end of year number two again the plants
gonna go into a dormant dormant
hibernative state that will carry over
into year number three and then just
like in year number two in year number
three the plant will continue to grow
now eventually I'm not saying this
always happens in the third year
eventually when the plant reaches its
age of sexual maturity it'll produce
flowers if pollination and fertilization
are successful it'll develop fruit and
inside of the fruit will be seeds this
doesn't always happen in year number
three like my notes say it might take
decades for this for a plant to reach
this stage it depends on the species as
we continue on in in my timeline up here
eventually in the winter months the
plant will enter a dormant stage which
will carry over to the following year
the following year in this case your
number for the plant is going to
continue to grow and ultimately produce
flower fruits and flowers fruits and
seeds and eventually nothing lives
forever eventually the plant is going to
die again I'm not implying this always
happens in year number four some plants
some angiosperms some perennials will
live for decades I even mentioned for
centuries before they die
all right so now we want to look at the
parts of a flower and here we have some
flowers they don't look very pretty
because they haven't bloomed yet or
blossomed and so as I mentioned earlier
flowers are the reproductive the
reproductive structure of angiosperms
gymnosperms do not make flowers neither
do ferns
neither do moss and so what we see right
now are the protective outer leaves and
these are called sepals now again
they're not going to protect from a
hurricane or anything - too strong but a
little bit of protection maybe from
frost maybe from insects and so those
are the sepals but eventually the sepals
are gonna peel away and when the sepals
peel away we can see the colorful petals
in this picture it's a great picture you
can see the the sepals are shrinking and
the bright in this case kind of a
pinkish lavenderish color the the bright
petals are beginning the show and so as
I mentioned earlier the petals are often
brightly colored because their purpose
is to attract pollinators they're trying
to spread pollen so they can reproduce
and so inside of the flower once the
petals open up inside of the petals is
where we can find the male and female
sex organs when we look at this picture
right here we see male and female sex
organs and I'll go over in just a moment
a moment which ones are male which ones
are female
I took these pictures the other day
while I was walking my dog and the
reason I took these pictures is you can
see neat little stages of a flower in
bloom here so in the picture you can see
here's about a dozen or so flowers all
bundled together growing from one stem
so about a dozen or so maybe give or
take a little more well a day earlier
this grouping of flowers looked like
this next picture watch this there you
go
a day earlier this is what the flowers
look like they hadn't bloomed yet so all
the petals were still together the
flower head and the petals hadn't spread
opened yet well a day earlier than this
turned back the clock a day this is what
they looked like a day earlier ah now
this is kind of interesting
notice how the entire bundle those
several dozen what we're soon to be
flowers are all kind of packed inside of
one group of sepals here so you can see
the sepals are protected several we are
soon to be several about a dozen or so
flowers
they just haven't bloomed yet in this
picture and a day earlier if I go back
24 hours earlier this is what they
looked like in this picture you can see
that the sepals are completely sealed
together and you can even see the bumpy
the bumpy buds and the inside of the
sepals so this is what we mean by the
sepals offer protection
so a moment ago I showed you male and
female parts but never really showed you
how to distinguish the two well here it
is
generally speaking the male parts around
the outside and the female parts are on
the inside and it kind of makes sense if
you surround them the female parts with
male parts that increases the odds of
getting pollen from the male to the
female here's another example of and
this is a lily the flower called a lily
and you can see the flower part the
female part in the middle and the male
parts all around again here's another
picture of the female part in the middle
and the male parts all around and the
last picture here of the female part in
the middle and the male parts all around
let's go into flower parts now and
figure out which one's which and what
are they called so when we look at the
flowers let's first look at the male
part of the flower the male part of the
flower are called the stamens in the
word stamen you can see em en for men
men means male and at the very top are
what we call the anthers the anthers
produce a whole lot of pollen and the
pollen will perhaps drift away in the
air or maybe a bee or some kind of other
insect will carry pollen from one plant
to another the anther is often elevated
into the air by what's called the
filament and it makes sense elevate the
anther in the air therefore a big gust
of wind is more likely to carry the
pollen the way so those are real really
only the male parts the majority of the
interesting events happen at the female
part let's go over that next oh forgot
before we go over that a question here
notice how the stamen which is the male
part surrounds the female part in the
middle why do you think this is well I
said that a moment ago is that the male
parts kind of are surrounding the female
parts because it increases the odds that
pollen goes from the male to the
okay so next for the female part you can
see in the diagram it's labeled the
pistol you also probably hear it called
the carpal maybe from look in the
textbook and so this is the female part
and you can see from the bracket that
the female part is made from a few other
parts so starting at the top and working
our way down the top the tip of the
female part is called the stigma it's
usually very sticky and it's sticky for
a reason it's trying to collect pollen
so little tiny microscopic pollen grains
can land on this and stick to it that's
called the stigma the stigma is elevated
into the air and I hope that makes sense
if you're trying to catch pollen out of
the wind then it kind of makes sense
elevate the stigma high into the air and
therefore you have a better chance of
grabbing and catching onto the pollen as
it drifts by and finally at the base of
the picture we have what's called the
ovaries the ovaries contain something
inside of them called an ovule sometimes
they contain more than one ovule if an
ovary has five ovules then there's a
chance that five seeds will grow if an
ovary only has one of you will like you
see in the picture the ovary in the
picture only has one ovule well then
it's only gonna make one seed so let's
go ahead and show how flowering plants
how angiosperms reproduce oh one thing I
forgot before we go onto the next slide
the ovary is the part of the flower that
will eventually grow into a fruit should
fertilization be successful so let's go
ahead and follow that process
so here we have a plant that's going to
do self pollination it's going to
pollinate itself if a flower has both
male and female parts then watch the
animation its own pollen can land on its
own stigma and therefore will will lead
to the fertilization process which we're
gonna go through in just a moment that's
called self pollinate
well also you could have what's called
cross-pollination here we have two
neighboring flowers watch the animation
pollen from one lands on the stigma of
another eventually this could lead to an
egg and sperm being creative being
fusing together to make a zygote and
that is what we're gonna talk about next
is how does the pollen eventually reach
the egg let's go into that
so here we have some apple trees so
let's look at the angiosperm lifecycle
using apple trees as our example
well let's zoom on in to one individual
flower of an apple tree alright when we
do we see an apple here and the notes
say pollen is gonna stick pollen sticks
to animals or it will often be released
into the wind and notice how there are
in this picture there's four there's
four anthers by the way four flower
parts does that make it a monocot or a
dicot I hope you know that would make it
a dicot flower parts and fours or fives
anyways back to our notes in the picture
here you see the four anthers are
covered in the red dots that's the
pollen watch the animation our bumblebee
flies in and is browsing around the
flower feeding on some of the neck there
gets pollen all over itself and then
flies away
so our bumblebee was covered in pollen
check out this picture here's a real
picture of bumble of a bumble bee just
absolutely covered in pollen
well this bumblebee is gonna fly away
and go to another neighboring flower
let's go and follow that next
so are the the notes say the bee is
gonna transfer the pollen to the stigma
of another flower here comes our bumble
bee it's got the red dots all over it
it's it's a wandering around feeding on
the nectar and then it flies away but
look what it left behind it looked be
left behind those three red dots on top
of the sticky stigma and so let's zoom
that in and take a closer look I only
drew I only drew one of the pollen
grains so there's the pollen grain just
for simplicity even though we saw three
red dots let's just focus on one but
notice how there's a black dot in the
middle that's the sperm inside of the
pollen grain look at the base okay I
just highlighted the ovary the brown
spot in the middle is the ovule and the
white dot in the middle of the ovule is
the egg how are we going to get the
sperm all the way down to the egg to
fertilize the egg
so now we're setting up the process of
fertilization like the notes say a
pollen tube watch this a pollen tube and
that red tube just grew from the pollen
and down into the ovule and so the
pollen tube is gonna grow downward well
there's a reason it's called a pollen
tube is that sperm is gonna travel down
that pollen tube so the sperm is gonna
eventually travel down the pollen tube
and fertilize the egg and there you go
you have the zygote watch the animation
here it goes down goes the sperm
fertilizes the egg and makes a Z in the
diagram the Z stands for zygote and that
a view-all you can see in the animation
the ovule just hardened into a seed with
the zygote trapped inside
eventually the zygote grows and grows
and forms a little embryo inside of the
seed and see that area labeled the ovary
that's gonna grow into a fruit now you
know because this is an apple tree
remember it's gonna grow into an apple
so here it goes the ovary is growing
into an apple you know the rest of the
flowers dies the petals the sepals all
that falls away and so the ovary becomes
the fruit with the seeds trapped inside
and eventually the seed excuse me
eventually the apple is going to fall
down to the ground well let's follow
that Apple
when we follow the Apple it just landed
on the ground and the title is called
dispersal because those seeds are gonna
be dispersed here comes a horse and the
horse is gonna eat the apple and I think
we know what's gonna happen in a little
bit well first of all the horse is gonna
gallop away let's go find that horse
so like the notes say a few hours later
here comes our horse and who knows where
it's been it's been running around and
eventually it goes to the bathroom and
in that steaming pile of poop our seeds
maybe not just one seed like you see it
could be many seeds but the seeds have a
big pile of fertilizer to grow in
there's a lot of leftover nutrients in
in poop nitrogen in particular so the
seed even has an advantage by growing
out of the poop and so over the over as
time passes that little seed might begin
to grow into a seedling basically a baby
apple tree and years and years and years
later here we go our there's our little
or grown up apple tree all cute all
grown up with its own flowers and so
there you go there's the angiosperm
diagram and life cycle and so if you're
in my biology class pause the video I'd
be happy to check your answers before
class or after class one day bring them
to me and let me see how you did good
luck